jamal adams on twitter with a fairly
well done photoshop of himself in a
seahawks uniform a little presumptuous
with the captain
patch on the jersey good chance he will
get the c but let's have the vote first
jamal but uh we're just kidding around
that's what it's going to look like for
jamal adams this year he heads to
seattle bradley macdougall goes to new
york to join marcus may and we are now
drafting the top safety duos currently
in the national football league chris
trivia question goes to you if you get
it right you get the first pick jamal
adams was one of two first-team all-pro
safeties in 2019
name the other
oh first team all-pro safety i i gotta
think the other one was hmm i want to
say tyron matthew
oh
micka fitzpatrick oh man
gosh man tyrone matthew wasn't i don't
know why i thought he was at all pro
safety too
he didn't get the credit that he
deserved last year and it seems like he
never does all right i'm starting and
this is a balancing act right you can
you can have one really good safety net
i know okay yes if you get two really
good ones then you know you got the best
duo and that's what they have in
minnesota because they kept anthony
harris he didn't sign a long-term
contract he's there under the franchise
tag for this year they have harrison
smith together the best duo at safety in
the national football league huge
responsibilities in that defense anthony
harris can can be in the right place at
the right time and make a big
interception harrison smith covers a lot
of ground and he brings a big stick when
it's time to make a tackle so to me that
was the no-brainer smith and harris
because both guys are at that level
where they are among the top in the
league yeah i i they were certainly in
the running for the first pick i still
can't believe i missed that with minka
fitzpatrick i'm still like pissed off
sitting here going how did i do that but
you're right these are this is the first
group i wrote down i mean harrison smith
i think you know awesome football player
um kind of you know on the downward
trajectory of his career anthony harris
is on the rise as one of the better ones
in the game so all right good pick by
you your vikings you got to pick the
vikings i'm going to seattle you know
you talk about the balancing act yeah
yeah the the damn scale has been
balanced real far you know gone one way
here and first off the other guy he's
gonna be paired with jamal adams and
quandre diggs is a pretty damn good
tandem quandre diggs i'm not sitting
here trying to tell you he's earl thomas
but went to texas like earl thomas and
has a similar skill set and is like just
a heat-seeking missile back there as far
as a free safety's concern unbelievable
range can play the pass game if you need
him to come down and make a tackle you
can do that and then of course jamal
adams for me you know we've been saying
this really all off season or at least i
have been i think he is the best safety
in football i think he's one of the best
defensive players in all of football uh
and i understand why seattle wanted to
do it because it's such a big position
for their team so yeah i'm gonna go with
that duo right now as as being top
yeah and uh you know you've made the
point earlier about how important that
is to the seattle defense and what it
does and what it means and how they they
have some balance now again they were
tilting toward the offense after the
legion of boom was gone well now it's
back in a big way with jamal adams it's
gonna be exciting to see what happens
all right i i uh man and now it gets a
little more difficult i'm gonna go to
new england yeah kevin mccordy and
patrick chung okay uh you know when you
think of that veteran defense and how
important it's going to be this year
to try to slow down opposing offenses
that may not be as prepared early in the
year as they otherwise would be
you've got that defense that that at
times last year early in the season
there were some superlatives being
thrown their way that that uh were
unjustified but at the time they were
justified they ultimately proved to be
not a defense that could live up to 85
bears type comparisons but mccourty and
chung athletic and smart and able to do
what is required of them in the bill
belichick defense and uh you know they
may not be the best two or among the
best two with any other team but in that
system that they know so well they get
it done and they deserve that
recognition well yeah you're right i
mean you know i mean come on
nobody gets recognition up in new
england you know except for one guy for
the last 20 years everybody else nobody
else talks about anybody else devin
mccordy is like
i mean he's one of the most underrated
players i think we've seen
you know in in the last 10 years or so
hands down been one of the best free
safeties in the game for a number of
years i mean phenomenal and then like
both guys to like to to bolster your
pick because i'm a nice guy i mean
they're swiss army knives i mean you
know they can cover guys like corners
devin mccourty can legitimately play
corner if you need him to i mean devin
mccord is a hall of famer for my money
he really is that's how special of a
player he is and and patrick chung is a
and a legend and certainly a patriots
hall of famer when all said and done so
i'm not mad at you there all right i'm
going to steal town you know i know
you're two hours away from pittsburgh
steelers and i like those two damn
safeties there you know minka
fitzpatrick of course jersey guy watched
him in high school got stuck in a bad
situation in miami it just shows you if
you're not in the right spot in the
right system i don't care who you are
it's hard to overcome it sometimes minka
fitzpatrick goes to pittsburgh and all
of a sudden we go whoa he's awesome he's
a superstar yeah he's a really damn good
player and then they got a first rounder
next to him in terrell edmonds out of
virginia tech who's a phenomenal
football player too more of the strong
safety in the box type but both can do
really anything and it's a huge region
excuse me there huge reason why they're
one of the best defenses of football
because you know they both can play in
the box play back cover guys and do
anything you want so
i like that duo a lot there in
pittsburgh
all right now it's getting difficult
um
[Music]
you know uh the i mean the the the
reconfigured jet secondary you could say
with bradley mcdougal and marcus may but
but i'm going to go with star potential
and i'm going to go with the guy
who technically you weren't incorrect
earlier tyron matthew was an all-pro
defensive back not an all-pro safe okay
that's what it was that's right
defensive back yeah i'll go tyron
matthew and juan thornhill in kansas
city because tyron matthew and anyone is
going to be among the top tandems at
safety because you get tyron matthew who
is a great leader who can do it all who
you can line up anywhere and uh is is
one of those guys that where you always
have to know where he is he's almost got
that that troy polamalu factor where you
need to hold the football an extra split
second before you throw it because you
need to make sure that that the honey
badger isn't lurking into that area
where you're thinking about throwing the
ball so uh
primarily because of tyrant matthew i'll
take the chief's defensive back yeah i'm
not mad at you there i mean first off
juan thornhill was phenomenal his rookie
year i mean he's a guy that was a great
great draft pick by brett veach and
company i mean it really was
he's and he got hurt at the end of the
season he didn't get to play in the
playoffs but i mean they were on my list
here as one of the top safety duo's in
football you know it'll be a little bit
about where thornhill's health is here
but you're right everything you said
about matthew come on i mean he'd he'd
be on my team any day of the week i'd
take him on in any sport i don't care
what it is now i don't know what the
hell to do there's so many you know i'm
here buffalo i feel like they're
underrated jordan poyer and micah hyde
you know the redskins with landon
collins and they signed sean davis you
know
hey
oh washington football team oh my gosh i
know i got it sorry everybody sorry
sorry yes all right i'm going to 49ers
though the hell with all that i'm going
jaquaski tart and jimmy ward first off
jimmy ward one of the most underrated
defensive players in the league you know
awesome free safety heat seeking missile
jaquaski tart plays that
cam chancellor position for that 49ers
defense i'm not saying he's cam
chancellor or jamal adams but he's
really good and he can do the things
that we've talked about already in the
show i mean he's pretty physical in the
run game and he can cover tight ends and
running backs out of the backfield so i
look at that as being one of the more
underrated duos in all of football
you know i may need to check the tape
here because i was still reeling from
the fact that that word made its way
into the program did you say heat
seeking miscle i don't i might have i
mean it's very very very easily i mean
you know what i meant you jerk but yes i
could have said this
yes uh all right well uh and there are
plenty of other capable
safety duos i mean i i elsewhere on my
list i've got the broncos jenkins and
marcus williams yeah in new orleans yeah
the broncos justin simmons and kareem
jackson yeah we could have thrown the
jets in there even without jamal adams
bradley mcdougal you know some people
were making the argument that bradley
macdougall is every bit as good as jamal
adams which clearly isn't the case or it
would have been a straight up trade um
so plenty of safety safeties get
overlooked we talked earlier about the
market less than 15 million dollars per
year for the top of the market jamal
adams may change that we will see
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports